[Musique]
jessica présidente directrice générale
d'une grande firme multinationale va
bientôt partir à la retraite
son entreprise et sa vie c'est son bébé
et elle veut la voir continuer à grandir
mais surtout elle ne veut pas
l'abandonner à n'importe qui
malheureusement le conseil
d'administration semble souhaiter voir
un certain daniel lui succéder jessica
des tests taniel et elle déteste rêve
voir daniel prendre au contrôle de sa
compagnie sauf que le conseil
d'administration le sait et jessica ne
pourra donc pas les influencer comme
elle le souhaiterait
désespérée elle se tourne vers
mathématicien le mathématicien demande à
jessica de lui faire un topo sur les
candidats potentiels
jessica dresse une liste de cinq
candidats on y trouve bien sûr daniel
mais aussi hors vie louis rachel et mike
jessica est persuadé que ravi en
particulier serait un candidat
prometteur et que le conseil
d'administration le sait elle est
persuadée que ravi mérite d'être le
prochain pdg de son entreprise elle
mathématicien n'est pas coin que il doit
en savoir plus que penser différents
membres du conseil d'administration
jessica affirme que le conseil
d'administration est composé de cinq
membres importants de qui va dépendre
l'issue du vote du prochain pdg
ses membres sont francis dogues pilz
claire et jessica elle même jessica les
connaît bien
elle est même quasiment certaines des
préférences des membres du conseil
d'administration
d'après elle francis préfère daniel à
rachel a avait à mike à louis dogues
préfère daniel alluis à mick harvey à
rachel peter préfère lui à daniel un mic
a ravi à rachel claire préfère rachel
mike a ravi à daniel enfin jessica
préféra ravi à rachel un mic à lui à
daniel jessica se tourner vers d'autres
mathématiciens à lui demande
que pouvez vous faire pour empêcher
l'élection de ce [ __ ] de daniel qui
n'a cessé de vouloir me voler mon
entreprise
le mathématicien intrigué rentrer chez
lui et armé de sa familiarité avec la
théorie mathématique des scrutins se met
à tester diverses combinaisons
commençons par imaginer ce qui se
passerait si on utilise ce scrutin le
plus basique qui soit à savoir le
scrutin à un tour dans ce scrutin chaque
membre du conseil d'administration
chaque électeur a le droit à un vote à
un candidat dans le cas où chacun des
électeurs votent pour son candidat
préféré
daniel gagnerait l'élection avec les
deux voix de francis et dog contrôler
une voix de lui venant de peter une voix
de rachel venant de claire et une voix
de renwez venant de jessica à moi qu
moins que claire et jessica ne s'allient
pour faire élire à chelles non ça ne
suffirait pas parce que peter pourrait
faire pencher la balance du côté de
daniel et du coup daniel serait quand
même et si on faisait une élection à
deux tours pourrait alors avoir un duel
entre rachel et daniel au second tour
mais non ça ne marcherait pas non plus
c'est encore daniel qui emporterait à
moins que à moins que jessica ne votent
oui au premier tour et du coup au second
tour c'est lui qui gagnerait contre
daniel mais oui ça ça marcherait ça
serait keller
il faudra réussir à justifier un système
à deux tours et puis les autres vrais
très bien que jessica n'a pas voté sont
ses vrais préférence au premier tour et
si on disait à chaque membre de voter
leur ordre de préférence en attribuant 4
points au premier choix trois points au
second choix deux points en troisième
choix un point en quatrième et 0 au
dernier daniel aurait alors quatre puces
cadre +3 plus euros +0 est égale à 11
points
rachel en aurait trois puces zéro plus
zéro + 4 + 3 est égal à 10 points
ravet en aura deux plus un plus un plus
un plus 4 est égal à 9 points mike en
aurait un + 2 + 2 + 2 + 2 est égal à 9
points et lui en aurait zéro + 3 + 4 + 3
+ 1 est égale à 11 points
nour est alors une égalité entre daniel
et louis jessica pour un maître lui en
premier dans ses préférences et lui sera
été le cas sauf que sauf que ce vote par
préférence et ce système de points
salaire trop compliqué à en poser
quoi qu'il en soit toutes ces analyses
préliminaires semblent indiquer que
louis est la clé de la solution
jessica n'a pas aimé ça n'a pas l'air
d'aimer lui beaucoup plus que daniel
sent pas bon ça sent pas bon tout ça
et si on faisait un scrutin par agenda
comme pour les tournois sportifs ont
fait des match qui oppose deux candidats
perdants est éliminé on continue ainsi
jusqu'à ce qu'il ne reste plus qu'un
seul candidat
on peut ainsi tester daniel contre lui
avait contre mike puis le vainqueur de
daniel contre lui jouera contre rachel
et on finit avec une finale entre les
deux restants si on fait un vote daniel
contre lui alors c'est lui qui gagne
avec les trois votes de peter claire et
jessica avait versus mike c'est michael
qui gagne lui versus rachel c'est rachel
qui gagne du coup on se retrouve avec
une finale entre rachel et mike et ping
osséja celle qui gagne sauf que sauf que
ce tableau de match est un peu
arbitraire
comment jessica pourra-t-elle convaincre
le conseil d'administration de
l'utiliser je sais on va utiliser un
agenda plus naturel on va commencer à
opposer les deux grands favoris
daniel et lui et comme ça on élimine
tout de suite daniel puis on pourra
enchaîner avec mike versus lui ça c'est
lui qui gagne
puis lui contre rachel et ça ça fera
gagner
rachel et enfin rachel versus ravis et
alors c'est avec qui gagne et ça ça va
plaire à jessica
lendemain au moment de passer au vote du
futur pdg jessica annonce d'un air
confiant que tout le monde sait que ça
va se jouer entre daniel et lui et
propose donc de voter à main levée
entre les deux les membres du conseil
pour qui gagne elle ou lui est l'un des
deux préférés sont tous d'accord à main
levée
c'est lui qui l'emportent jessica
annonce du coup que lui et le nouveau
pdg
mais c'est alors que francis quitté test
lui rajoute qu'il y a tout de même
d'autres candidats et qui ne serait pas
sérieux de ne pas les prendre en compte
soit que pensez-vous de mike lance tout
à coup jessica le vote entre louis et
mike est effectué et mike père jessica
se tourner vers francis et lui demande
du coup une autre suggestion francis
rétorque oui rachel bien sûr le vote
entre rachel et lui tourne maintenant
al'avantage de rachel qui est maintenant
la nouvelle futur pdg
et là c'est au tour de peter & dogs de
s'indigner peter & dogs dernière macho
affirme que rachel n'a pas les épaules
pour tenir l'entreprise
peter & dogs dos au mur suggère alors le
nom de harvey et francis réplique alors
pas lui suivi de claire qui affirme que
rachel est largement assez compétente et
que peter est dogues font preuve la de
sexisme le conseil d'administration
devient alors bouillon bruyant et
désorganisée jessica feignant d'être à
bout de nerfs exigé alors le silence
s'il vous plaît on va faire ce vote
mais ça va être le terrain et vote le
vote qui va déterminer le futur pdg de
l'entreprise sera donc celui entre
rachel et harvey et comme jessica
l'avait anticipé sert avec gagne
jessica l'annoncent alors officiellement
d'une voix neutre qui ne laisse pas
transparaître le triomphalisme qu'elle
ressens intérieurement
ainsi soit il le conseil
d'administration a voté
harvey sera mon successeur il sera le
prochain pdg de notre entreprise
elle est forte cette jessica est le plus
fou dans toute cette histoire c'est que
le conseil d'administration pense que
l'élection de rave et est parfaitement
légitime en particulier personne ne
soupçonne que le choix du pdg a été
façonnée bien avant la réunion du
conseil d'administration par la main
invisible d'un mathématicien
malveillants alors on pourrait croire
que l'histoire que je raconte est là sur
jessica hervé tout comme les séries
soute et saufs car oui les noms et les
photos des personnages viennent de ces
séries si vous connaissez pas je voulais
reprendre
on pourrait croire que tout ce que j'ai
racontée là mais que pure fiction
ce que je vous ai raconté la est en fait
inspirée du livre public jeune sera
adoucie en chef de futurs use in game
fihri de bronze bueno de mesquita
chercheurs en théorie des jeux qui vend
des prédictions géopolitique aux agences
de sécurité américaine et dont le être
accueilli corde est meilleur que celui
des avis des experts
et dans ce livre mesquita il parle de la
fois où il a été embauché par un pdg
bientôt à la retraite pour faire tourner
la balance dans le bon sens dans
l'élection du prochain pdg et on
reparlera bien plus longuement de
beaucoup d'aspects de ce livre dans
cette série sur la démocratie
ce que je veux que vous reteniez de
cette vidéo c'est que le processus
électoral affecte grandement l'issue
d'un vote et ceux ci transforme de loin
le problème de la politique
en fait ce dont je vais essayer de vous
convaincre dans cette série de vidéos
sur la démocratie c'est que l'on peut
grandement affecté le futur de nos
sociétés en nous concentrant sur le
choix du scrutin que l'on veut mettre en
place
en particulier on peut faire beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup mieux que les scrutins
qui existe aujourd'hui et qui ont des
conséquences extrêmement néfastes sur
notre manière de réfléchir et de penser
non seulement la politique mais aussi
divers sujets de société dans la
prochaine vidéo j'essaierai de vous
convaincre que les scrutins à un tour et
à deux tours qui l'utilisent beaucoup
aujourd'hui à travers le monde nous
pousse à nous diviser et favorise ainsi
les concepts d'opposition ou de vote
protestataire
et ça c'est peut-être une des sources
majeures des pseudosciences et des
idéologies extrémistes
une vidéo qui suit juste après on
parlera de scrutin alternatif qui ont de
bien meilleures propriétés que les
scrutins à un tour et à deux tours et
ensuite dans cette série sur démocratie
on verra d'autres applications de la
théorie des jeux à la manière de penser
nos sociétés l'objectif final sera de
vous montrer comment les mathématiques
appliquées grandement affecté ma
compréhension de nos sociétés et comment
elles peuvent nous permettre de mieux
décider ce qu'il faut faire à ce qu'il
ne faut pas faire pour annoncer des
lendemains meilleurs
j'espère que vous avez aimé cette vidéo
et que vous êtes assez excité pour cette
nouvelle série de vidéos sur scène ce
fol ça va être des trucs beaucoup plus
abordable que tourments la fin des
séries précédentes où j'avais d'assez
loin je voulais je voulais parler la
télé alors ça veut pas dire qu'il n'ya
pas de mathématiques super sophistiqué
derrière ce dont je vais parler dans
cette série sur la démocratie
mais ce que je vais présenter va être
beaucoup plus compréhensible y aura
quand même des épisodes art sport par ci
par là pour complémenter les fondements
mathématiques de ce que je présente et
d'ailleurs il y aura pas que des
mathématiques appliquées dans cette
série on va aussi mettre en avant des
idées d'économie ou de psychologie pour
essayer de mieux comprendre ce qu'il
faut faire pour mieux structurer nos
démocraties je tiens aussi à signer que
ne faut pas compter sur moi pour prendre
parti politique pour défendre un parti
ou un candidat plutôt qu'un autre
dans cette série sur la démocratie je
vais essayer vraiment de vous parler de
la manière de penser la démocratie en
général et indépendamment du contexte
de données par l'actualité en
particulier toutes les vidéos de cette
série j'espère en tout cas seront encore
valable dans cinq ans dans dix ans du
coup cette série de vidéos sera très
détaché de l'actualité et en particulier
je vais vraiment éviter de parler
surtout des candidats actuels à la
présidentielle du coup j'aimerais aussi
que dans les commentaires vous éviter de
tomber dans des débats qui ont à voir
avec les politiciens d'aujourd'hui
je pense que ce qui fait vraiment la
force des mathématiques appliquées
notamment de la théorie des jeux vu de
façon abcès abstraite pour compenser les
démocraties c'est que justement elle
s'abstrait elles se détachent des
détails de démocratie telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui pour essayer de mieux pensé
prendre du recul et cd mieux penser les
choses dans leur généralité
donc c'est une approche qui contraste
sans doute pas mal avec 99 % de ce que
vous pouvez lire dans les médias ou sur
internet
et voilà j'espère que en cela ça va vous
permettre d'apporter vraiment nous notre
eau nos nouvelles à votre bilan ça veut
dire que je restais sur des idées très
plate je pense qu'on va aller très très
loin sur l'analyse démocratie on va
aborder des théories dont vous avez sans
doute encore jamais entendu parler si
vous avez aimé cet épisode penser à le
leak et à le commenter et surtout à le
partager pensez à vous abonner pour ne
pas manquer aux épisodes merci aux ti
peur pour leurs dons et j'espère
vraiment que je vous verrai la prochaine
fois nous avons déjà cinq façons
différentes de déterminer le gagnant et
chacune de ces méthodes sur base même
résultat donne un vainqueur différent
le vote stratégique c'est quand on ne
vote pas selon ses convictions mais
qu'on exploite les failles du système
pour aider son candidat